definitely guys yeah for a guy or girl
anyone
or both either or
i mean i would say for a guy
yeah it's kind of a little weird you
call them incels
but i would say for a girl if she's 21
and she actually is a virgin i think
a lot of guys would
probably not believe her but if if they
know that to be a fact they'd probably
find that like really
attractive
you think so yeah you think that you
think a virgin girl is attractive
i mean i think if a girl's attractive
she's attractive i know i'm saying do
you think you're stretched to a man
i would say so hmm
you were going to say something you were
like no
no i'm not saying what he said wasn't
right about a guy i find that attractive
she was 21 and a virgin but i think all
my friends lost their virginity like at
like 14 or something 15 and then i
remember i lost my virginity like a
couple days before my 18th and i
definitely felt like no one directly
pressured me or all my friends weren't
like oh go and do it but it was kind of
like you did feel like a ticking time
bomb because it did feel a little bit
like
where when everyone's doing one thing if
you're doing something different you
feel a bit weird so it's like when i was
coming up to my 18th it did feel like i
was getting to the weird stage
oh really you felt yeah i felt like
awkward like you have to get it done
yeah
but i can't put my finger on where that
come from i guess it's just the norm
because the average
age of people losing their virginity is
actually around 17.
oh okay see compared to like everyone i
know that's really late
do you wonder if um
those numbers are based on like an older
generation because i just hear stories
from my younger sisters about like their
friends tell us the stories pal no no
i'm i'm not talking about anything with
minors
sorry
no
no no no
um but
there's just wild stories when they're
doing stuff where like
like at a much younger age it seems like
than the older generation so you think
there's more pressure on like the
younger generation to lose it and i
don't even know if it's pressure i just
think they're wilder like i just think
they're exposed to more younger and i
think that like my mom's generation
would say that about my generation right
like it seems like every generation is
just getting wilder and wilder and
wilder
so a lot of times like when i see the
stats it's always based on like five to
ten years ago and i'm like it's a whole
different group of kids um
see i remember when i was gonna lose my
virginity i'm never gonna lie as a guy
like
i prepared
because like you as a guy you kind of
prepare like you know
what's gonna happen i knew the day i had
my girlfriend she had already had sex i
hadn't but i never told her that
obviously because
i was experienced
and um like you just prepare for it like
it was that the same was it like a was
it something that you kind of fell into
or something that you prepared for
for me personally i fell into it oh
really okay yeah it wasn't it wasn't the
preparation it wasn't it was just am i
sorry
um yeah no it wasn't it wasn't
yeah i didn't prepare for it as
as you said yeah but you know it just
happened organically
you guys did you prepare i i definitely
prepared for like a month
mentally and like spiritually
absolutely prepared uh and like in my
case it was very similar what you're
saying is i didn't want to be the only
one in my friend group who's a virgin so
i just found the first girl who had a
crush on me and i just begged her to let
me hook up with her and she was super
enemy so she's like yeah totally and i
prepared for it right because talking
women was never easy
right right and so
yeah definitely something to prepare for
how do you prepare for this
is it
look for advice on and this is like over
a decade ago right so this is like yeah
it was a long time ago and i i was just
trying to mentally prepare for the most
part and um did it help definitely
definitely i had no idea what i was
doing i just like stuck it in just
waiting for something to happen i was
just confused
it was very very confused as it got
better
did you have to prepare over there i'm
not married sorry i couldn't tell you
guys oh you're american
he's a virgin we got a virgin on the
show no i don't know if i like prepared
but
yeah it kind of just happened but i
already kind of was wanting it to happen
actually the very first time i had the
option to do it it i couldn't make it
happen i was like too nervous and the
girl was older than me she wanted to and
i just couldn't
without being descriptive here but uh
yeah i just couldn't get hard i was like
too nervous i was really young yeah like
really young how young really young i
think i was like a freshman in high
school i don't know how old it is over
here um 14 no i was like 12 or 13. what
the heck
yeah
yeah girls had crushes on me when i was
young and then um
but yeah it was until later it was
probably like a year and a half two
years later
after that wow wow
like
you're like in a different one 12 and 13
i was just like thinking about like
computer games and [ __ ] i was trying to
get laid at that age i really
we go to catholic school and i feel like
the girls would feel guilty
like after if they lost their virginity
to be honest like just in my friend
group i guess
because
that's what it goes like i definitely
did because i was older i was definitely
the last one in my friend group but like
i felt so guilty
because i felt like god was like mad
he's still mad no
i know i know he's still there
so
that pressure at 12 so i just want to
kind of flesh that out like where do you
think that came from
like where did it because a 12 to me a
12 year old would be thinking about
different things other than sex i was
probably like 13. that she was a junior
so she was probably like 15 or 16.
she was just like an older girl to me
like the a year or two makes a
difference in high school right you know
and then she was like she's already done
it she was experienced i wasn't so she
was like 14.
her she was probably like 15 or 16 right
okay yeah
um
i don't know you just never done it
you're nervous you hear about it you see
all these adult films and you're a kid
you're like yeah back then actually we
didn't have the internet like you know
i'm 34 i forgot to mention earlier but i
remember like when we were in elementary
school someone found this
adult magazine right from their dad and
they ripped out a page so we used to
have to walk home from the bus stop and
there was like this desert where we'd
hide this one picture just a still
picture of a girl with her boobs
and like we were all like young kids
staring at this thing and we'd hide it
back under this rock throw dirt on it
and like we'd stop by there like every
day to look at it so do you think like
your introduction to like losing the
virginity was
probably not healthy
was something like that like because i
think a lot of guys like even me like i
had i was introduced to like a corn
videotape when i was like 13. and blew
my mind so young to me i'm like this is
like
no literally like like i had a friend
and he was at his house and he knew he
was older than me he was like 15. i was
like 13. and
he knew that his mother had like a corn
video that's vhs times like she had like
a vhs and he was like guys there was
like three of us and i was like guys i'm
going to show you something
and um he put the tape on and that
at 13 that literally blew my mind yeah
one of the greatest days of my teenage
life was
that's corn stash like
everything changed
i have a question for the guys um would
you want to marry a virgin definitely
yes yeah
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible